if at first the mere notion of the
divided consciousness was characterized
by the effort to set aside its
particular individuality and to become
the unchangeable consciousness its
efforts from now on are directed to
rather to setting aside his relation
with the pure formless unchangeable and
to coming into relation only with the
unchangeable in its embodied or
incarnate form for the oneness of the
particular individual with the
unchangeable it's henceforth the essence
and the object for this consciousness
Justins in the mere notion of it the
formless abstract unchangeable was the
essential object and the relation of
this absolute divided 'no so the notion
is now what what it has to turn away
from the initially external relation to
the incarnate unchangeable is an alien
reality has to be transformed into a
relation in which it becomes absolutely
one with
in paragraph 213 Hegel is not telling us
anything radically new that he hasn't
already been developing in the previous
paragraphs but he's bringing things to a
close as he so often does to try to
remind us of how far we've come he's
going to talk about this transition
that's taking place and he's going to
introduce a little bit of additional
content here so let's see what he's what
he's actually saying he says the mere
notion of the divided consciousness was
characterized by efforts to set aside
its particular individuality so he's
what we've got here is just sort of xing
it up right against the particular
individuality at the start that is
trying to that face itself because it
realizes its own contingency and says i
want to connect up with what is more
important more real more essential this
is going to be what's what's essential
as well as we go through this paragraph
more essential than than me language is
beyond that which is transcendent so he
says it tries to become the unchangeable
consciousness it tries to lose itself
and to become something else and this is
not going to be a resting place although
it will be at certain stages in the
dialectic for some people and some
cultures but what we're going to see
instead where there's any sort of
progress being made is that there's
going to be a transition now and he says
that the efforts from now on are
directed to setting aside its relations
with the pure formless unchangeable so
what we can say is we're sort of xing
manna now doesn't that raise a problem
we're getting away from what is
essential this this person or this
consciousness realizes him or herself as
unassembled as that which is worthy of
being a face because it's purely
contingent in relation to what is
greater than it so if we if we're going
to devalue what is greater than it and
also devalue this relation what are we
going to replace it with
well the pure formless unchangeable
becomes the unchangeable in a different
way and that's where this this this you
know important transition point has been
you know charted out by Hegel here here
over and over again in the last several
paragraphs and now the the initiative
you can say shifts to this this
relationship that the person the
individual consciousness is establishing
with the unchangeable in and embody and
the German here is Stoll Tintin so that
should you know make us think you know
just all right Abel's not choosing this
word just out of the blue it reminds us
that we're dealing with a shape a
configuration of structure of
consciousness now what what gets
particularly interesting about this is
he talks about the oneness or the unity
the ensign between the particular
individuality and the unchangeableness
now over here the individuality trying
to continue to be with the unchangeable
just by getting rid of itself okay
that's one way that's going to stay in
unity destroy the the entire side that
is keeping things from being unified but
that's not really an adequate way of
attaining unity instead this constant
effort as he says he has to do with the
relation between the particular
individuality and the unchangeable in
this this embodied or incarnate of the
gestalt inform he says the oneness of
the particular individual with the
unchanged unchangeable this relation
between them is henceforth the essence
the Bazin and the object that Gaston for
this consciousness just as in the mere
notion of the formless on abstract
unchangeable this was the essential
argument now is no longer
just this that's the essential object
it's the entire relationship between
them that is the essential object so
yours only says the relation of this
absolute divided miss the notion is now
what it has to turn away from so what do
we what are we trying to do we're trying
to get away from this sort of schism or
split within consciousness because
remember both sides of this are in fact
consciousness and instead find some way
to grasp or grapple with or even better
yet articulate this unity between the
two so it says the initially external
relation to the incarnate unchangeable
is an alien reality because this is
something different than the particular
individuality remember this is an
individuality standing over and against
the particular individuality that that
is engaged with them so how do they
assert a kind of unity between them a
back and forth relation that's where
we're trying to move next in the
following paragraphs
the movement in which the unofficial
consciousness strives to attain this
oneness is itself threefold in
accordance with the threefold relation
this consciousness will have with its
incarnate beyond first as pure
consciousness second as a particular
individual who approaches the actual
world in the forms of desire and work
third as a consciousness that is aware
of its own being for self we have now to
see how these three modes of its beating
are present and determined in that
general relationship
in this very short paragraph 214 Hegel
is laying out for us a three-part
progression that we're going to now move
through in the remainder of the
paragraphs running throughout this
section and he says that what we've got
here are two threefold things or two
threefold well we might call schemas or
arrangements that are directly
correlated to each other so we've got a
three-fold movement a movement on what
part on the part of consciousness
primarily coming from the side of the
individual consciousness where the the
activity the initiative lies in trying
to reconcile itself with the the
unchangeable the essential the the
universal and it's also correlated to
this threefold relation or connection or
way of being related to what - its
incarnate beyond - the gestalt attend
games games iyx means on the other sides
are like the the Latin ultra as opposed
to kid from being on this side games
IDEs beyond on the other side right
it could be something we don't know it
would just be something that's over
there that's taunting us okay you stop
that then we we sit we saw already that
this is a very deliberate you know word
choice on and Hegel's part something
that does in fact have shaped something
that does in fact have formed we can
translate it here as incarnate or as
embodied in part because human form is
is one of the highest ones for for Hegel
as well as the other German idealist so
there are three main movements three
main relations here one is pure
consciousness in relation to its its
incarnate beyond so what are we talking
about here there's kind of an ambiguity
running through this are we talking
about what it is
is that the determinant particular
contingent individual consciousness is
encountering the pure consciousness that
would be the beyond the essential well
yes except that now we've already moved
beyond that right so we've left that
behind and now it's actually the
individual who is grasping the embodied
the embody beyond the the individual and
beyond the individual in transcendent in
terms of their own pure consciousness so
what we've got here is a kind of
replication on the side of the subject
as opposed to the far off distant object
of their desire there what you know
yearning their their estrangement so the
pure consciousness is within the
individual subject and then we move from
there to grasping it as the particular
individual of these being who approaches
the actual world actual world as how
Miller translates very tight and there's
no reason why not to translate it that
way you can also say an actuality
approaches what is actual what gives
itself as is real how does that happen
typically well we saw this already work
itself out in the sections earlier in
self-consciousness in turns out of
desire the geared up and work our white
right we saw this in terms of the slave
that was put to work we saw this in
terms of both the master and the slave
in terms of their desire the slave
having to defer to this desire the
master getting to enjoy the objects of
his desire and so this this recurrence
of desire and work is going to be quite
important it's not just laboring and on
material objects for economic
consumption and expressing power
relations that Hegel is interest
here in talking about desire to work he
thinks that this runs throughout the
essence of what it is to be a human
being and throughout all of human
culture so this is going to be a very
important moment that we're going to see
taken up in some of the later paragraphs
and then finally the third movement the
third relation to this is incarnate
beyond consciousness aware of its own
being for self this is where the
reconciliation is supposed to take place
and the you know not just know this is a
reunification that the realization of
the fact that consciousness has been
both polarities both sides be
unchangeable and the contingent
individual and so it certainly doesn't
have to be unhappy anymore right this is
the realm of what Hegel told us earlier
in this development the realm of spirit
at first then this consciousness being
taken as pure consciousness the
incarnate unchangeable when it is an
object for pure consciousness seems to
be present in its own proper nature but
this its own proper nature has not yet
come into existence and as we have
already remarked in order that it should
appear in consciousness and its own
proper nature this would certainly have
to come about from its side rather than
from the side of consciousness thus its
presence here is at first only
one-sidedly due to consciousness and
just for that reason is not perfect and
genuine but remains burdened with
imperfection or an antithesis
in paragraph 215 what we see here is the
beginnings of the attempt of the
concrete individual through this
modality of pure consciousness to grasp
the object that it has been trying to
move towards which is the unchangeable
but now in terms of being incarnate that
is Gestalt inton right having some sort
of shape we've left the the beyond of
the totally alien abstract unrelatable
beyond behind and now the individual is
trying to connect itself up with with
this but it finds it that's not actually
going to work out as well as it wants to
in terms of pure consciousness why not
well it's treating this as its object
and Hegel is going to say the incurrent
unchangeable when it's an object for
pure consciousness seems that's the key
term there seems to be present in its
own proper nature so it's giving itself
as it is but then it's not now why isn't
it well you know why do we have this not
yet here it was dot dot dot it is this
ellipsis think about what it means to
actually be in current we saw this in an
earlier paragraph where Hegel talks
about you know making things incarnate
at least in terms of you know human
relatedness you know something that we
can connect up with something like
another individual doesn't get rid of
the opaqueness and lack of you know
things being there on the surface
because what is it about human
individuals then they are themselves
these deep things that we don't see
everything of at a first glance so it's
going to be the same thing with the
incarnate unchangeable except now it's
in terms of agency yeah there's a
fundamental why that's not being
answered here or even really raised so
he says this proper nature has not
come into existence as we've already
remarked why is that this this you know
proper nature of the incarnate
unchangeable not yet come into existence
because it would need instead of just
being an object for consciousness which
is reaching out for it it would need
itself Ana's consciousness to be self
giving and that's not happening when the
the concrete individual is just trying
to cognize it so that's not going to
provide it what it means it says this
would have to come about from inside
rather than from the side of
consciousness so what does that mean its
presence this is this presence here what
it what it's getting is here only at
first one-sidedly due to consciousness
consciousness is doing its best to try
to grasp this but this side over here
which consciousness can't force is still
out to launch you you might say or
you're waiting for it that's being
deferred so you know what we're looking
at here is the object giving itself as
subject and if it truly is another
subject it cannot be coerced it cannot
be you know you're required to show
itself it has to actually show us them
this is a dynamic by the way that we're
going to see it emerge much later on
when we talked about revealed religion
so he goes on and he says because of
that the the it's not perfect and
genuine but it remains burdened with
imperfection or an antithesis it has a
lack of fulfillment there is an
antithesis involved that gives us in in
German literally in opposition so when
you see antithesis here don't think
synthesis antithesis thesis we're going
to think there's an opposition in the
very side of the universal the the
eternal the unchangeable and so this is
not going to be
a complete fulfillment on the part of
consciousness that is attempting to
reach out and grasp it
you know the happy consciousness does
not have the enjoyment of this presence
it has at the same time advanced beyond
pure thinking insofar as this is the
abstract thinking of Stoicism which
turns its back and individuality
altogether and beyond the merely and
subtle thinking of skepticism which is
in fact only individuality in the form
of an unconscious contradiction and
ceaseless movement it has advanced
beyond both of these it brings and holds
together pure thinking and particular
individuality but has not yet risen to
that thinking where consciousness as a
particular individuality is reconciled
with pure thought itself it occupies you
rather this immediate intermediate
position where abstract thinking is in
contact with the individuality of
consciousness qua individuality the only
happy consciousness is this contact it
is the unity of pure thinking and
individuality also it knows itself to be
this thinking individuality or pure
thinking and knows the unchangeable
itself essentially and as an
individuality but what it does not know
is that this it's object the
unchangeable which it knows essentially
in the form of individuality is its own
self it is itself the individuality of
consciousness
paragraph 216 continues to churn out
this attempt of the individual as pure
consciousness that in in that mode
trying to grasp the unchangeable and
their relation to the unchangeable
ultimately trying to move towards an
identity with it and in this section
Kegel is going to do a little bit of a
retrospective summarization in terms of
stoicism and skepticism the two earlier
sections and then he's going to see how
there is you know in advance has been
made but where do the impasse still lies
so let's look at what he has to say
about stoicism and skepticism he says in
stoicism there was an advance right it's
it's be there there was this abstract
thinking that turned its back on a
rejected individuality wanting to reject
it in favor of the pureness the the
freedom of general thought of abstract
thought so as a person passing through
stoicism in the way that he was
construing it I would in in fact be an
individual this is one of the paradoxes
involved but I would want to sort of
preclude from or an abstract from that
individuality and understand myself in
terms of these general criteria of the
true and the good the rational and
thereby free myself and we saw that for
Hegel stoicism well it's an advance past
the earlier stages is is going to itself
run into a kind of you know impasse or
we're not being able to you know so
skepticism is going to come after that
not necessarily historically but in
terms of the development of the
dialectic in terms of the thought and in
skepticism we see again the power of the
negative the freedom inherent in human
thinking distinctively human thinking
coming to the fore but what do we end up
with what's our end result merely
unsettled think
as he says in which individuality is its
presence but as an unconscious
contradiction or as restless movement so
stoicism takes the contingency that's
that skepticism rather takes the
contingency that stoicism was unable to
digest you might think of stoicism as
making a cannon like an oyster making a
pearl around the little irritating grain
of contingency right and skepticism
breaks the pearl open it breaks
everything else open and says they even
breaks the shell that it finds out oh I
needed that so there's this Restless
movement and skepticism ends up being
not just self-defeating in an abstract
way but I'm unable to really satisfy
what it was aiming it you know the
skeptics were skeptical they were
seekers they were trying to get to
something and skepticism and founders on
its own advances you could say so he
says the unhappy consciousness is an
advance beyond these and it advances
beyond these it brings and holds
together pure thinking in particular
individuality so that's good right I
mean that's what these were aiming at
the trouble is is that the the unhappy
consciousness is not able to bring these
together and harmonize them with each
other that's going to have to happen
later on but it is setting the stage it
is saying well look these ways of
understanding this opposition were not
productive let me see if I can find
another way that will in fact be more
productive so he says it's not yet
written to that thinking where
consciousness as a particular individual
is reconciled with pure thought itself
instead we've gotten when it calls an
intermediate position where the abstract
thinking is in contact with the
individual
individuality of consciousness ply
individuality now I've got this as
individuality here in parentheses
because I think that there is an
intentional ambiguity in Hegel's text
that was reflected in the English but is
also present in the German so we can
think of the relationship or the content
of the whole room between pure thinking
or abstract thinking have the individual
write the particular individual abstract
thinking is related to the individual
insofar as the individual is individual
insofar as the individual is acting like
an individual is you know contingent for
example going off in all the different
directions that these were able to call
attention to there's another way of
reading this sentence which is that
abstract thinking is related to
individuality as abstract thinking is
individuality because who carries out
abstract thinking the answer I'm
thinking exists in some sort of void
often never-never-land doing its own
thing exercising its only agency we
often talk as if it does right and even
the most anti anti plainest you know the
most anti you realist of people often
lapse into that sort of toy abstract
thinking is abstraction that is carried
out by a subject so unless we're going
to you know say well there's the mind of
God and our ideas correspond to those
and the mind of God the Wayne State
Thomas Aquinas was was able to do or
earlier thinkers if we're thinking about
something imminent you know the way
Hegel is talking but imminently
developing we don't really have that
option any more abstract thinking is
already involved in individuality and
contingency that's bad for a thinking
isn't it well we'll see some more
you know results of that later on in the
reason section but keep that in here in
the back of your mind so the user when
he says this is this into an
intermediate position the unhappy
consciousness is this contact between
thinking and individuality it is this
this opposition it is holding both of
them together
but says it also knows itself to be this
thinking individuality or pure thinking
and it knows the unchangeable itself
essentially as an individuality so
there's all these advances that are made
but still there are opposition's there
are even we can say contradictions Gagan
that's right we saw in the last
paragraph then this is this is an
embodied in and what he tells us in the
last sentence about this what it does
not know it being the unhappy
consciousness is that it then it's
object the unchangeable which it knows
essentially in the form of individuality
is its own self is itself the
individuality of consciousness so we see
it again there's you know central theme
pertaining to the unhappy consciousness
that we have to polarities we have the
the essential and we have the individual
we have the universal and we have the
particular contingent person we have the
unchangeable we have the not only
changeable but changing all the time we
have abstract thought and we have you
know the individuality that has to end
up being the basis for abstract thought
and these seem to be in opposition to
each other they are in opposition to
each other insofar as consciousness has
not yet realized that not only does it
have this conflict within consciousness
but it also has the reconciliation for
that that conflict within consciousness
as well why doesn't it realize that the
reconciliation has not yet been carried
out merely thinking the term
reconciliation are all well this stuff
all works out together does not actually
make it so there has to be a
development
you